but it's like that's that's iMessage
audio voicemail and that's Geo you're
talking to I think that's just a group
chat Clubhouse was just like live
podcasting yeah I knew my message was
gonna go down so
[Music]
anybody here a fan of Mr Beast I love Mr
Beast if you have [ __ ] to talk about Mr
Beast I'll just [ __ ] leave I haven't
seen one video I have a confession to
make I have [ __ ] to talk about Mr B's
can you bounce
I have a confession to make I've never
seen a Mr Beast video but I've heard
that he is a YouTube genius he's the
Michael Jordan of YouTube pretty much
right he is yeah yeah Steve don't leave
I'm out of here no we didn't mean it no
no come back Steve
do you know him personally is that why
no no I don't know why does he look like
he's gonna spill the hot sauce no no
please Steve
doors
no don't help him I just want to see if
the [ __ ] feel all that [ __ ] dude
thank you oh he's really leaving [ __ ]
guys Mr Beast is a [ __ ]
I didn't say anything bad about him we
didn't even get a chance to say anything
he has Uber here is it Uber pool oh my
Uber's gonna be here in a minute
I'm not here yet oh [ __ ] all right I'm
gonna wait inside
it's hot
I'm wearing [ __ ] huge tracksuit so
it's just hot but yeah we'll go I'm so
surprised you didn't spill anything okay
so
um Mr Beast believes Tick Tock will die
soon what dude because he's right dude
everything dies in like three years man
we just [ __ ] got started what what
yeah what is he basing that off of
because I hope it dies soon what is your
what is your speculation what was before
Tick Tock Vine maybe Instagram what
happened to vine it's dead what happened
to uh that [ __ ] one with the yellow
icon Snapchat Snapchat Gone Gone But
Tick Tock seems bigger but with Vine
Chinese
why did Vine fail why did Snapchat fail
vinefield because of Kylie Jenner
apparently really she came out and said
it was lame oh no it was Snapchat
Snapchat
vinefield honestly because they just
um six seconds right yeah I think it was
just it was just one of those flashing
the pan things that like
they were they wanted to sell it quickly
like I think the people behind it just
wanted to [ __ ] sell it to somebody
else quickly they helped like Google
would buy it or somebody but I don't
think anyone bit in time
yeah because that's what happened to
Snapchat if you remember they got like a
four billion dollar offer and they
actually turned down Google who then
turned Instagram into like
having a Snapchat option like the
stories which are pretty much Snapchat
yep
so so they're like [ __ ] you we'll just
do our own thing we don't care and then
and then and then later Snapchat's like
oh [ __ ] we should think that but that's
like the whole classic zucking right the
Zuckerberg element right yeah and it's
what Bill Gates did with Microsoft he
took everything that you were going to
offer and just did it for free and if
you're gonna you're gonna sell it to
Microsoft cool that's easier for him but
if not we'll iterate our [ __ ] we'll
build out and we'll just do your [ __ ]
for free and give it out during the
suite of Microsoft that's how the Sony
PlayStation happened they were supposed
to do a deal with Nintendo yeah and then
they it went bad and they went all right
we'll just make it [ __ ] my [ __ ] Sony
console exactly that's why there's like
maybe four I think that exist of like
the um the Sony and Nintendo prototype
yeah pretty cool that does sound cool it
is really good Sony Nintendo prototype
that's unreleased there's only a couple
of them yeah but they exist well so uh
recently on Mr BEAST's um
YouTube show type thing what is it
called he says a full send podcast for
anybody who listens to Mr Beast uh he
talks about Tick Tock because somebody
had asked him uh was asked if Tick Tock
would eventually take over his beloved
YouTube now I think it's important to
understand that Mr Beast is like the
king of YouTube which makes it he's the
biggest thing maybe there's a biased
element to his perspective on it but at
the same time you can't be a king of
something and not know something that
other people he's the he's the girl he's
the goat right I think he said that uh
he got offered a billion dollars for his
YouTube he was got he did get offered a
billion dollars and he turned it down
and that's crazy that is crazy he
doesn't I mean for some reason he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the money was
just tight yeah
have you
have you uh Rogan yeah like because like
jorro was like oh you got to be [ __ ]
balling right he goes no actually I'm in
debt he's like puts all of it back yeah
he's like because he's like I have like
eight videos or however many all going
on at once and each one of them costs
like 10 20 million to make so it's
literally ad Revenue comes in here and
then I have to like he'll build entire
warehouses just to shoot like one thing
yeah then him not selling for a billion
I think he's stupid as [ __ ] I agree with
you that's who cares with a date he
doesn't care about money like I don't
yeah but people do his game is like I
just want to make the best YouTube video
ever yeah well he gives away a lot of
money too yeah I always see him give 10
G's to people which is like pretty
[ __ ] crazy dude can you imagine just
like Mr Beast on an off night and you're
like a waitress at Applebee's and like
Mr B comes in he's tired and then you're
like you you see me like oh my God I
can't believe this [ __ ] and he's like oh
I'm just here to get like a [ __ ] I
just want to get a burger I'm here for
the two for 20.
he's like what what coupons you guys got
going on this cat's like I'm not trying
to give you 500 I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not gonna keep 500. every interaction
that guy has must be nuts oh I bet yeah
they all think it's like you know oh my
are you gonna change my life right now
oh no sorry I'm just I'm wearing my
sweatpants and like you're always
wearing sweatpants he's like oh [ __ ]
that's like that's like Epic Man in the
90s that's true Publisher's clear now
same effect yeah so again if I used to
carry the big check everywhere
when Mr Beast was asked if Tick Tock
would eventually take over his beloved
YouTube he responded and said I thought
the same but YouTube shorts they've
really taken some huge strides and all
comes down to the money so YouTube
shorts and I think this is a very very
pertinent conversation to where we are
today because my man Ryan you know what
I'm saying well I'm trying to keep it
Anonymous I'm I didn't say anything I
just said my mom looking for like
Anonymous props yeah Anonymous props
point is whoever it is in the JK Empire
they're telling you that has now been
transitioning our content both to
YouTube shorts it's not Barton jump
[Laughter]
hey little tip of the trade there uh
if you still haven't figured it out yeah
like uh definitely not definitely new
but now now that now that JK content for
the first time ever in [ __ ] 16 years
plus of existence writer has finally got
on both YouTube shorts and Tick Tock I
think this is an important conversation
for us to at least be ever so slightly
ahead of the curve on in our our own
analysis or understanding right so
the reason why Tick Tock my diet and
YouTube Again by Mr BEAST's words for
sure will live on and be a reigning
champion of social media at the end of
the day always comes down to money right
he said quote unquote so starting in
January if you get like hypothetically a
billion views on Tick Tock whatever that
is that's like a thousand dollars
exactly
yeah from what I understand Tech talkers
don't make that much money unless it's
like from Brand deals or something yeah
you have to use brand deals for your
[ __ ] views over here on YouTube I
mean that could literally make you a
hundred thousand dollars Mr B said yeah
something so there's more parody in the
in in the on network [ __ ] and then he
said the host then asked is Tick Tock
going to adapt to that you think
Mr Beast replied yeah I think they're
going to be forced to
he was also asked what he thought this
meant for the biggest tick tock Stars he
said
Charlie demilio Addison Ray all these
people if they can just literally do
what they're doing but over on YouTube
and make a bag off of shorts and then on
top of that that boosts long form which
makes even more money you're going to be
crazy to be a tick tock first content
creator so Tick Tock which would be a
supplement to drive traffic well because
Utah YouTube shorts right now they're
putting a rumor has it slash whatever
confirmed reports and stuff like that
for everybody who understands on the
back end they're putting a [ __ ] ton of
money into YouTube shorts let me just
ask you this would you rather get three
main views on YouTube or tick tock
as a Creator you too duh so that's the
whole thing yes longer shelf life yeah
and then on top of that right they're
talking about the fact that when you
have something like YouTube shorts which
let's say it's effectively Tick Tock but
YouTube right it's the same [ __ ]
concept but YouTube and then let's say
you also do YouTube long form content
but because you're on the same platform
it's it's immediate direct connection
yeah you go right to the page then you
have all the Content Library why would
you not capitalize on that single
connection to optimize your content
creation versus like multiple platforms
let alone the fact that based off what
he's saying there's gonna be even more
money that goes into YouTube shorts
specifically than Tick Tock by itself
regardless of the fact that you make
long-form content that can be like you
know I mean like bumped onto that it's
just One's Gonna Pay you a lot more why
would you just do Tick Tock yeah that's
kind of like a lot of his argument you
know what I mean the weird thing is that
like for a long time since the beginning
every everybody already knew that about
Tick Tock and it hasn't stopped more
people from consuming it yeah so
in the end it's just wherever
everybody's at right yeah but the
incentive to make more money is probably
going to drive people to another
platform the main content creators yeah
but then maybe that'll that'll pull the
audience also who's the audience on Tick
Tock right it's it's generally kids like
less likely to have any kind of income
to purchase things like merch or
anything like like that would help a
Creator who's like trying to sell
something so that that's another
economic reality that people don't know
about but also there are some things
that only
um like then you're looking at the odds
of a person with money wanting to buy
something or the odds that a parent will
just say yes to buying a kid something
they asked for
so there's that too because most parents
have the money to buy their kid some
dumb [ __ ] for Christmas but that means
that we need to have a [ __ ] stupid
app and a stupid game that is monetized
but we but we don't I mean look at
fortnite like that's not something
that's like directed at adults that's
mainly kids that's mainly kids that
don't have money yeah it makes millions
a [ __ ] year you know and it's a free
game but if you know parents who deal
with fortnite like it's it's like that
it's like holy [ __ ] like
that's all the kid wants it's all they
want it's how I reward them if you I
mean the cool thing I think about tech
talk is you're able to get a ton of
eyeballs yeah and so if you know how to
monetize those eyeballs they're not good
for you right it's it's on you that like
the funnels for it yeah they they're
making like seven figures and all
they're doing is [ __ ] teaching how to
flex your triceps and [ __ ] I'm like God
damn that's [ __ ] crazy which is crazy
because it's such an oversaturated
Market too you could find that anywhere
yeah and yet they still make those
numbers right because there's so many
eyes the cool thing is that one thing I
do believe is like when Tick Tock dies
if it does by that time there will
already be a different one running the
newest one that's coming up is that what
is the one where it's like it takes both
pictures and back that's the newest one
I heard and Tick Tock copy that too
right
be real yeah be real yeah I think that's
the newest one I heard they got Tick
Tock now like a different subset yeah
it's kind of similar
but yeah I think there's always going to
be that like other come up app that just
gets a ton of people using it like look
at [ __ ] what was that one shitty
audio one that everyone was going crazy
you know musically it's a precursor
usually with some dog [ __ ] though giant
chat rooms yeah the chat room ones oh
yeah [ __ ] Clubhouse Clubhouse like
people were [ __ ] people were [ __ ]
over that and it was the dumbest thing
and we all knew that it would never get
on clubhouse I was like [ __ ] no it's so
whack it was only only did a great job
of launching during coven that's it yeah
because people were just [ __ ] bored
and lonely and like we're entrepreneurs
so like I'm an entrepreneur I should be
in like an entrepreneurial place I'm
like oh yeah hello everybody hello
fellow entrepreneurs what are we all
talking about today there was I will
give a credit there was there was a blip
of magic to clubhouse though no it was
whack in the beginning the minute that I
heard it might have been whacked to you
the minute that I heard it where I was
like wait so people debate and instead
of taking like two hours because people
go back and forth they're responding
when they have time this debate is going
to take three weeks you know because
it's like Nick says something I don't
know that Nick said something and then I
go what did Nick say about me and it's
[ __ ] Tuesday oh yeah
and then Nick is [ __ ] living his life
and on Thursday that's not how close
I love you
I love you I love you and I respect you
yeah we're all like wait is that like
the beta version that might be just
WhatsApp don't think Bart knows what
Clubhouse is but it's like that's that's
iMessage audio voicemail and that's Geo
you're talking to I think that's just a
group chat Clubhouse was just like live
podcasting yeah I knew my message was
gonna go down so
categories so like you could pick a
category and like you could go in there
and [ __ ] info all I'm saying when I
heard somebody talk up Clubhouse one of
the things that I didn't wasn't able to
shake even though I wasn't like super
big fan of Clubhouse they're like yo I
was in a [ __ ] chat room in
conversation with like XYZ celebrity or
people that they couldn't reach normally
and then they maybe got brought up to
like talk as a guest or whatever and
then suddenly you're in a again
non-visual chat room with like some of
your like [ __ ] favorite people
specific to the industry and you're like
I would have never had a [ __ ]
conversation with this cat and I was
like that is crazy it's like when Elon
Musk yeah but once it blew up too much
then it's like you're never gonna
[ __ ] get into those rooms anyway now
it's big so so I think when it was very
just beginning there was magic but then
once I think everybody was like this
valuable when they came over it's like
there's no more it was like 19 days of
value
I think that was the number I think it
was 19. all I know is he was trying to
take down iMessage yeah I don't know
what that was he's on The Voice Memos
too
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]